What is green building?
It's an integrative process that focuses on the relationship...
...between the built environment and the natural environment.
Buildings can have both positive and negative impacts...
...on their surroundings...
...as well as the people who inhabit them every day.
Reduced energy and water use, healthy indoor environmental quality,...
...smart material selection and the building's effects on its site...
...are key considerations of a green building.
Sound familiar?
It should,...
...as these elements mirror the different credit categories...
...within the LEED rating system.
These buildings cause less harm, could do more good,...
...which creates a more sustainable environment for all.
LEED acts as a decision-making framework for project teams...
...during the life cycle of a building,...
...which includes planning, design, construction and operations.
LEED rewards best practices, innovation...
...and recognizes exemplary performance...
...with different levels of certification.
In other words, LEED is green building.